-Whenever Donald Trump
holds a press conference,
his rambling nonsensical answers
raise more questions
than they answer.
So we decided to hold another
one right here, right now.
That's right. Donald Trump,
and the "Late Night" Press Corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go.
So without further ado,
it's time for the "Late Night"
White House press conference.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Mr. President, Mr. President,
Mr. President, Mr. President.
Mr. President, yes, thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
President Trump, how would you
describe the current state
of your presidency?
-In the final couple of weeks.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Mr. President, what would
you say to Mike Pence,
who was probably hoping
that you'd be impeached by now,
and he'd be the president?
-Too bad, Mike.
[ Laughter ]
-How long have you been
president?
-For like 44 years or something.
[ Laughter ]
-I haven't seen Jared Kushner
in a while. Where is he?
-Being held hostage...
in Venezuela.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, did you hear that my wife
and I had a second child?
-Congratulations. I'm sure
you're very unhappy about that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You bragged that when you ran
the Miss Universe Pageant,
you used to barge into
the dressing room.
What did you do when
you went in there?
-I'd say, come on,
let me see what you have.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you tell your barber?
-Make it look like not good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey, how's Melania?
-I don't know if she likes me
anymore, but that's okay.
She used to.
-What do you see when you
stand on the bathroom scale?
-Large, large numbers.
[ Laughter ]
-What's the hardest part
about having a threesome?
-You can't do them
simultaneously, by the way.
Just think if somebody said,
"Oh, you can do them both."
No, you can't. Because
if they're doing that,
we're not doing the other.
[ Laughter ]
-What's between your ears?
-Beautiful, perfect air.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Can you tell me what words
would you use
to describe yourself?
An ignorant, narcissistic,
racist?
-Those words. Those exact words.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-How often do you have
an empathetic human thought?
-Averaging one per decade.
[ Laughter ]
-Every time I make biscuits --
you know when you make biscuits?
Well, when I make biscuits,
they turn out really dry.
What should I do?
-Speak to Mr. Pillsbury.
[ Laughter ]
-Important question here --
how many children do you have?
-It looks like three.
Could be four.
Perhaps it could be two.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that your final answer?
-Two, or one, or three.
-You're almost there.
-One, or two, or three,
or four, or five.
[ Ding! ]
-Hey, you got it!
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, I'd like to finish
with the same question
I always ask.
President Trump,
how's your penis?
-It'll never hold up.
[ Laughter ]
-How's your penis?
-Little, almost not at all.
-And how is your penis?
-That's such a racist question.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, then how's your penis?
-Pretty nasty
to be honest with you.
-Well, looks like
we're out of time.